let's now shift the focus to another
huge issue and one of the biggest
challenges of our time climate change
africa is bearing the branch of the
global climate emergency the u.n says
climate change threatens to expose over
100 million vulnerable africans to
droughts flats and extreme heat by 2030
one of the worst-hit countries is
somalia almost 8 million people there or
about half the country's population are
facing crisis hunger levels the most
affected area is the bay region in the
south the un says barring a massive
influx of assistance that region is
likely to see a full-scale farming in
the coming months
southern somalia this is what the worst
drought in decades looks like
people displaced by climate change and
conflict
their only source of water is this
distribution center in a displaced
persons camp
the united nations humanitarian agency
has been sounding the alarm for some
time
i've been shocked
to my core these past few days
by the level of pain and suffering
we see so many somalis enduring
famine
is at the door
and today we are receiving a final
warning
it's been four failed rainy seasons in a
row
and now the un's as a fifth one is on
the way
but the problems in somalia run even
deeper
decades of civil conflict
mass displacement
and one of the lowest standards of
living in the world
what's happening in the horn of africa
is a threat to a way of life
which has sustained families and
communities for generations
it's not just a lack of rain
for four seasons
for many families it's an end
to the way they've lived
a surge in food prices worldwide and a
grain shortage triggered by the war in
ukraine have made the situation worse
this entire region is on the brink of
extreme hunger waiting in vain for the
drought to end
clearly to prevent such impacts of
climate change in africa something needs
to be done urgently and industrialized
countries need to fulfill their funding
promises for contributing the most to
climate change that's a point that was
reiterated by ghana's president nanco
fuado i was earlier this week in
rotterdam
africa contributes the least to the
climate
emergency
responsible for less than four percent
of global emissions
yet we are facing increasing and more
intense climate-related extreme events
we are indeed at the crossroads
if we want our continent to thrive we
have to adapt to climate change
and to achieve this
adaptation financing needs to start
flowing at scale
and that's why earlier this week african
leaders traveled to the africa
adaptation summit in rotterdam
netherlands but european partners did
not turn up and that was strongly
criticized by african leaders
i want to note with a taste of
bitterness the absence of the leaders of
the industrialized world
i think that if we made the effort to
leave africa and come to rotterdam
it was easier for the others to be here
they are the main polluters of the
planet and they are the ones who have to
finance adaptations
and as we've observed
the private sector one of the main
polluters is also absent
that gives us a taste of unfinished
business before even starting this
meeting
i just had to express this
disappointment
i would also like to deploy the absence
of leaders of the industrialized nations
as well as the representatives of the
private sector
[Music]
they are the biggest polluters
and would have had to answer to our
questions here
the absence of european leaders clearly
disappointing for african leaders as my
colleague christine mundoer who was at
the summit also reports
i am in the dutch city of rotterdam and
while this country the netherlands is
one of the wealthiest in the world it
too faces an existential threat as it
pertains to climate change but the
difference is this country has been able
to invest in the infrastructure needed
to literally keep the country afloat
now have a look at that building behind
me that is literally the world's largest
floating office to give you a sense of
what i'm talking about it is in that
very building that global leaders
gathered for the africa adaptation
summit over the years we've seen the
international community make huge
pledges and commitments to helping
africa in with climate finance but that
money hasn't necessarily always followed
through and now this summit which was
held right before the cop summit coming
up in egypt uh in november the idea was
to get leaders on board to get that
renewed commitment but we have to talk
about the elephant that wasn't in the
room and that is that while african
presidents made the trip to be in
rotterdam the european counterparts
largely snubbed the conference and so
that did set the turn but nevertheless
we were able to get a conversation with
the president of the african development
bank akinwumi addishina who spoke about
the urgency for africa and the cost of
inaction africa is actually suffering
africa is in a
terrible situation with regard to
climate you seek out floods that are
happening you take the situation in
zimbabwe you check the case in malawi
you check the case also
in zambia that were pummeled by a
hurricane i mean the cyclone died that
destroyed more than 2.5 billion dollars
uh water of infrastructure you take a
look at pastrani you know cyclone that
hit madagascar you know and totally
decimated many things across the country
you know and put about 600 000 farmers
they couldn't really um you know it was
flooded and so they put in that support
you look at the um horn of africa that
is suffering for immense amounts of heat
low cost
that are all linked to climate change
you look at the sahelian region of
africa you know all across the sahel you
know you have drought and all of that so
basically africa is not just um being
affected by climate change is totally
distressed by climate change and
therefore the whole issue is africa
which contributed no more than three
percent of the problems we have today is
suffering a deluge of problems as a
result of that you know we lose on the
continent today
anything between seven and 15 billion
dollars a year as a result of climate
change and we have very very low income
country
countries generally and if we don't get
enough climate finance that will rise to
50 billion dollars
a year you can imagine how much that is
for us almost seven percent of our gdp
would be will be
lost because of uh of of climate change
and so we do need to have a lot and and
the amount of climate finance that
africa needs we need anything between
112 billion dollars a year to 125
billion dollars a year
but africa is only getting three percent
of global finance right and so which
means that africa which actually did not
cause climate change is now suffering
disproportionately from that and that's
why for us at african development bank
we decided to take a bold effort right
we say well look we're not just going to
wait for everybody else we're going to
go out and start doing climate
adaptation monies for ourselves from the
african development bank so we launched
what's called the african adaptation
acceleration program we like to call it
three-point ap right much easier to
remember exactly yeah 3.8 is pretty
easier to remember but what's the goal
we decided to mobilize 25 billion
dollars to support climate action for uh
for africa together with the global
center on adaptation and to show that we
really mean business
the african development bank put down
12.5 billion dollars out of the truck 25
billion so we're just trying to raise
2.5 billion
for that but that said it's still very
small regarding you know compared to
what we need to do so what we need to do
is that
the 100 billion dollars a year
that were promised by the developed
countries to developing countries to
support climate
finance in particular adaptation for
africa really needs to be on the table
you know i like encouragement you know
uh which is good but encouragement must
translate into finance concretely some
of the money that you've talked about
that the bank for example uh has has
made investments or can you tell us
where this money is going and what is it
actually doing okay let me just take the
case of agriculture food security you
know we provided we have a program
that's called technologies for african
agricultural transformation it's a
platform that brings the
highly performing technologies climate
resilient technologies to farmers at
scale you know i don't like mickey mouse
stuff i don't like little stuff i like
big things africa has 1.4 billion people
we must be working at scale and that's
the scale at which we work at the
african development bank so for example
take the case of wheat
okay wheat is a temperate crop right
but we've been able to provide wheat
varieties to african countries now that
are
heat tolerant with varieties which means
they can grow in hot environments so we
provided that to sudan in 2018
and sudan
in two years was able to reduce its
wheat import by 50 percent as a result
of this heat tolerance take the case of
ethiopia now just to give you a sense we
gave them 65 000 uh metric tons of seed
now i don't want to be technical but
just just tell you what that is so if
you take an airbus right 380 aircraft
okay with the largest spade giant planes
big giant place okay the total weight of
the people of the cargo of the foil is
98.4 uh metric tons so when i say we
provided ethiopia with 65 000 metric
tons of seed that's about
666
airbus 380 aircraft packed on the
landing strip to the brim so you can
just imagine full with seed now it
revolutionized and transformed things
for ethiopia
in 2018 they cultivated these new
varieties on hitler and varieties on 5
000 hectares right by
2021 20 20 21 they had reached one uh 87
000 hectares right
and by this year they had reached 645
000 hectares so that for the first time
in utopia's history they didn't import
wheat this year
next year the prime minister tells me
about that they will become a net
exporter wow of wheat for the first time
in their history so that is the kind of
technologies that we're talking about
that we do i'll give you another example
of what we do we have a program called
african disaster risk insurance facility
which basically when countries go
through drought you know you got to
ensure your farmers your pastoralists
because they lose a lot of their animals
and stuff like that all the countries
have catastrophic risk events you know
you have to insure your countries
because you have to take money out of
your public financing to repair
infrastructure and all of that so this
particular one we did it for
we now have about 10 countries that we
support with it and a good example was
madagascar
when the cyclone bistro hit it
we actually insured them with four
million dollars against catastrophic
risk event so when that happened they
were able to get an insurance payout
of 12 million dollars which allowed them
to be able to accomplish 600 000 farmers
that were affected by this so that is
the kind of practical things that we are
talking about in terms of action at
scale
mr president thank you very much for
your time sir thank you so much
you